bonjour à tous il ya du nouveau au
niveau des smartphones au niveau de vos
smartphones de vos appareils les écrans
vont changer l'année dernière c'était
des écrans bord à bord qui ont vu le
jour et c'est ce qui a cartonné l'année
prochaine ça va être des écrans pliables
et je vous en parle tout de suite
[Musique]
les écrans pliables c'est vraiment la
nouveauté 2018 samsung galaxy x surface
phone apple aussi devraient s'y mettre
il ya lenovo zinc est sur le coup un
petit peu moins bien failli à énormément
de smartphones qui se met en place qui
devrait sortir en 2018 et les écrans
pliables c'est vraiment la nouvelle
tendance la nouveauté pour 2018 et
justement va regarder ça ensemble et on
va diviser cette vidéo en trois parties
la première partie c'est ce que l'on
sait marque par marque on va regarder
les produits un peu et les tendances qui
se dessinent pour 2018 ensuite on a
regardé parce que l'on ne sait pas ce
qu'on ignore et puis ensuite on va
regarder la troisième partie ce qui est
sûr les infos sur je vous invite à vous
abonner parce que les écrans pliables on
va en parler énormément et d'ici
quelques jours je serai au cs le plus
gros salon high-tech à las vegas qui
présente toutes les nouvelles tendances
donc s'il ya des écrans pliables en 2018
c'est sûr qu'ils seront là bas donc
abonnez-vous on reste connectés et on va
les voir ça ensemble les écrans pliables
doivent répondre à une problématique
on veut des écrans toujours plus grand
pour avoir un meilleur confort de
lecture par contre en vue des
smartphones toujours plus compacts donc
comment faire pour avoir un smartphone
compact qui tient dans la main qui tient
dans la poche avec des écrans plus
grands il ya un moment c'est un peu une
équation compliquée donc pour y répondre
la meilleure solution c'est d'avoir
effectivement des écrans pliables des
smartphones qui peuvent se plier déplié
alors on va tout de suite commencer par
ceux que l'on sait ce que l'on sait
c'est que samsung s'apprête en 2018 à
sortir son samsung galaxy x d'ailleurs
j'en ai déjà parlé si vous voulez
vraiment connaître un peu les
spécifications de ce produit toutes les
rumeurs très très complète sur ce
produit il ya la fiche qui est si
samsung galaxy icsa devrait vraiment
être un tournant le tout premier
smartphone avec un écran pliable de
l'histoire une vraie avancée une vraie
innovation et là où apple il ya dix ans
en a sorti son premier iphone qui a
vraiment lancé les smartphones qui a
créé quelque chose de nouveau la samsung
s'il arrive à lancer ce galaxy x avant
tout le monde et à sortir un écran
pliable avant tout le monde ils vont
vraiment prendre le pas sur cette
deuxième décennie des smartphones
effectivement plus 2011 ont déjà annoncé
travailler sur un smartphone avec un
écran
ampli ya beaucoup de spéculations on l'a
énormément attendu pour l'instant on n'a
jamais rien vu venir sauf que là ça se
précise et en 2018 ce samsung galaxy x
devrait arriver très clairement c'est un
produit qui devrait être révolutionnaire
depuis la première keynote d'apple où
l'iphone est annoncé le mot
révolutionnaire révolution dans l'en but
face à toutes les sauces sauf que là
vraiment pris un coup avec ce smartphone
avec un écran pliable il devrait
vraiment y avoir quelque chose de
complètement révolutionnaire alors pour
l'instant on sait pas exactement quelle
forme il aura quelles têtes il aura à
quoi ressemblera et comment gaspiller
l'écran et quelle manière mais ce dont
on est sûr c'est qu'on aura un écran
complet qui va réellement se plier et ça
ça va être quelque chose de complètement
dingue autres smartphones qui devraient
arriver en 2018 avec un écran pliable
c'est le surface phone de microsoft
microsoft c'est vraiment planté au
niveau des smartphones live vraiment
revenir en force avec un produit avec un
écran complètement pliable il avait déjà
un petit peu cette idée de ce produit
dans les tuyaux depuis quelques années
rien n'avait été fait là ont vraiment la
tendance s'accentue et s'accélère là
dessus donc il devrait rattraper leur
retard ça serait peut-être un smartphone
plus dédié aux professionnels pour
l'instant pas trop d'infos concrètes là
dessus mais des créations d'artistes où
on peut effectivement voir à quoi
pourrait ressembler ce produit par
rapport aux différents brevets qui ont
été déposées c'est un smartphone qui
pourraient se plier à la manière d'une
tablette vous auriez un espèce de
bouquins un bouc que vous pourriez
effectivement plier ouvrir fermer comme
une tablette alors comme le yoga de
lenovo comme le yoga book de lenovo
avoir réellement à quoi ça va ressembler
mais en tout cas sans papiers ça va être
hyper séduisant 10 points d'ailleurs ce
que vous en pensez vous mettez des
commentaires à ce que tous ces
smartphones pourrait vous intéresser que
ce soit le samsung galaxy s que ce soit
le surface phone mark et moi tout seul
qu'est ce que vous en pensez tous ses
smartphones vous il devrait pouvoir
ensuite se replier grâce à des aimants
comme je le dis tourner sur des
charnières bon là j'ai l'impression de
faire un petit peu l'oiseau je ne sais
quoi mais bon cinquième faute d'avoir
produit majeur moule ministre avec mes
mains à serrer un peu du cirque il
devrait tourner sous une version
spéciale de windows 10 et il porte le
nom de code en gros da une info
d'ailleurs qui est venue du site the
wind centrale point com qui a dit que ce
produit va sortir un peu plus tôt prévu
normalement d'ici mars avril microsoft
devrait faire une annonce officielle
donc on en saura très rapidement
beaucoup plus sur ce produit autre
constructeur est dans la course ses
ouailles ouais alors ouais ouais c'est
richard view qui est le grand patron de
la division grand public de chez huawei
qui a confié lors d'une interview donnée
au site cnet.com et qu'ils avaient
effectivement réussi à créer un écran
pliable fonctionnel qu'ils avaient un
prototype de smartphone effectivement
avec un écran pliable alors sauf que
leurs écrans pliables pour l'instant ce
sont deux smartphones avec une petite
sharlie au milieu ce qu'ils veulent
vraiment réussir à terme c'est à enlever
cette charnière pour n'avoir qu'un seul
grand écran est normalement en 2018 on
devrait pouvoir retrouver ce produit
annoncé chez huawei on comprend très
bien que si oui oui maîtrise ses écrans
pliables on y retrouvera également chez
au nord parce que au nord comme vous le
savez ou si vous ignorez c'est une
filiale de huawei et on imagine qu'il va
y avoir une contamination après au
niveau de tous nos smartphones façon les
écrans pme les retrouvera quasiment
partout lenovo aussi dans la course ils
ont montré d'ailleurs en prototype l'été
dernier d'un smartphone avec un écran
pliable mi-smartphone mi-tablette sur la
démo on se rend pas vraiment compte mais
tout ce qu'on voit c'est qu'il ya une
technologie qui est maîtrisée avec un
écran complètement pliable et c'est
super esthétique c'est vraiment un
produit qui est super bowl est nouveau
avec ses produits avec sa yoga excès
yoga book pour avoir pu les tester les
et c'est d'ailleurs dans cette vidéo là
j'ai fait un test un homme boxing je
vous invite à aller voir parce que les
produits sont amants d'une super qualité
super résistant qu'on imagine un
introduit les nouveaux avec un écran
pliable ça va juste être de la bombe
atomique
apple normalement aussi ne serait pas en
reste être avéré également sur un écran
pliable probablement en partenariat avec
lg pourquoi avec lg pour contrecarrer
samsung et son galaxy x apple a fait une
demande de dépôt de brevets ce qu'on
voit très clairement dans cette demande
de dépôt de brevets c'est que les écrans
pliables on devrait les retrouver
partout chez apple que ce soit sur des
smartphones que ce soit sur des
ordinaires eur / démontre connecter sur
des tablettes cette techno devrait être
omniprésente dans les années à venir sur
tous les produits apple il ya un autre
fabricant qui est dans la course qui a
déjà lancé un produit qui s'appelle zte
alors été ils ont lancé un produit
d'écran pliable mais c'est pas
réellement un seul écran pliable ce sont
deux écrans pliables vous avez vos deux
écrans côte à côte vous pouvez
effectivement les bouger bon il ya un
côté un peu techno intéressante le fait
d'avoir ces deux écrans qui mis côte à
côte on a l'impression qu'on un plus
grand écran mais on voit très bien qu'il
ya des bombes sur le côté ce produit a
vraiment été mis pour essayer d'apporter
quelque chose de nouveau de coupe un peu
l'herbe sous le pied aux autres de faire
parler de son produit mais très
clairement c'est pas du tout un écran
pliable deuxième partie qu'est ce qu'on
ignore qu est-ce qu on ne sait pas on ne
sait pas réellement à quelle date vont
sortir exactement ses produits ses
produits devraient arriver en 2018 ce
qui est clair c'est que le premier à
dégainer aida remportera le trophée
remportera la palme mais pour l'instant
pas de date de sortie officielle donc on
sait très bien que les constructeurs
sont en train de se livrer une bataille
et travailler à fond pour être le
premier à dégainer et sortir son premier
smartphone avec un écran pliable
deuxième point qu'on ne connaît pas ses
prix on imagine très bien que ses
smartphones avec l'innovation la
recherche développement en arrière ils
vont coûter très cher probablement plus
de 1000 euros même c'est que présidente
claire quasiment sur plus de 1000 euros
j'imagine des produits peut-être me me
3500 que même imaginé jusqu'à mille
notes 2000 euros le smartphone alors
smartphone imaginons la version tablette
imaginons la version montre connectés
parce qu'on peut décliner sur l'ensemble
des produits d'une gamme donc de toute
façon quelque chose qui va coûter cher
après ce qui est sûr c'est qu'une fois
que les produits sont démocratisés
conrad partout ça coûtera beaucoup moins
cher mais dès le départ pour les
premières personnes qui ont voulu les
acheter il va falloir sortir le
porte-monnaie autre point qu'on ne sait
pas est ce qu'il y aura réellement un
seul écran pliable ou alors deux écrans
pliables comme sur le produit zte alors
à mon avis si on veut qu'il ya un vrai
intérêt s'il veut si un fabricant veut
vraiment gagner cette course est arrivé
en premier en tête il faut un seul écran
pliable pour l'instant rien n'est sûr
mais elle allait quasiment à 99% on aura
un seul écran pliable alors maintenant
on va regarder ce dont on est sûr ce
qu'on est sûr c'est que les grands
constructeurs les principaux
constructeurs de smartphones travaille
dessus parce que c'est vraiment l'enjeu
majeur pour 2018 2010cette ça a été les
écrans bord à bord on les a vus arriver
one plus chez samsung maintenant chez
apple chez tous les concurrents ce soir
weiwei au nord les écrans les grands
écrans le bord à bord pas exactement
mais en tout cas les grands écrans on
était vraiment la grande tendance
2017-2018 la tendance sont les écrans
pliables le premier arrivé le premier à
dégainer c'est celui qui gagnera c'est
celui qui restera dans l'histoire comme
étant le premier constructeur à avoir
sorti un smartphone avec un écran
pliable voilà un peu les infos qu'on a
aujourd'hui sur ses écrans pliables pour
les smartphones tablettes montre
ordinateur on peut imaginer énormément
d'applications dites moi vous ce que
vous en pensez à ce que c'est quelque
chose qui pourrait vous intéresser
est-ce que vous vous sentez concerné par
ces techno est ce que vous trouvez ça
intéressant mark et moi tout ça en
commentaire parce que c'est réellement
passionnant là on est en train de parler
de vos objets connectés de demain ce
soit votre smartphone votre ordinateur
votre enfant tout ça ça je vous ai déjà
dit donc restez connectés abonnez vous
laissez-moi des jolies pousser cette
vidéo vous intéressé je vous invite à
laisser tous vos commentaires pour dire
ce que vous en pensez et surtout on
reste ensemble parce qu'on va aller voir
tout ça de plus près ensemble ocs et de
toute façon ce qui est sûr c'est que ocs
il ya toutes les nouvelles tendances
aller dénicher aller renifler la barre
technique mon pire chercher soyez sûrs
que les écrans pliables je vais aller
les chercher je veux aller trouver et on
va en parler ensemble donc restez
connectés à très bientôt d'ici là portez
vous bien soyez sages je vous embrasse
je souhaite encore une excellente année
2010 8 ciao
[Musique]